at any time of year a visitor to India
would be overwhelmed by his beauty and
color but a visitor in late fall is
especially fortunate the temperature
will have filled down the monsoons will
have not yet begun and Diwali the
festival of lights is at hand
Diwali is too many Indians what
Christmas is to Christians in essence it
commemorates the victory of the forces
of light over the forces of darkness
to experience it fully get up before
dawn and head for the flower markets
here flower vendors work feverishly to
create Garland's of fragrant jasmine
that Indians will use to adorn their
homes by dawn they'll be sold out next
head for one of the temples but go early
later on in the day they'll be packed on
your way over you may see a curious
sight people hunched in front of their
doorways pouring colored sand on the
ground the sand takes the shape of a
lotus blossom a symbol of welcome and
today millions of symbols of welcome
will grace the nation's doorways indeed
Diwali is all about sharing if you're
staying in a private home don't be
surprised if the neighbors show up with
plates of delicious holiday trees it's
also customary for families to go to the
temples together on this day they often
dress and find new outfits purchased
especially for Diwali and if their
outfits inspire you or for a saree shop
shops are open on Diwali and Indian
silks are justifiably famous for their
beauty they're just one of the ways
India spruces up and gets into the
holiday spirit so this is an occasion
for all of us to rejoice and be with the
family and enjoy all the good things in
life so we buy good clothes and make
good food in everywhere there are lights
if you head to major commercial
districts throughout India you'll find
colorful displays possible to Christmas
lights in western cities some cities
also put on spectacular public displays
of fireworks like this one in Delhi but
no matter where you are there are
smaller more intimate fireworks displays
a long day of celebrations is coming to
an end and it's going out with a bang
you